die geschichte beginnt in der schweiz im
rheintal und sie führt in die ganze welt
es geht um waffen und kriege und armeen
und an den wissenschaftler namens kann
ohne das netzwerk während pakistan rollt
er wahrscheinlich keine atommacht
es ist die geschichte über die atombombe
die gefährlichste waffe der welt ist
einer der gefährlichsten kriminellen
dieser welt der mehr tat für die
verbreitung von atombomben technologie
als jede andere
er wird behindert respektiert und
geliebt von der pakistanischen nation
[Applaus]
dann wird lkn verraten von einem
schweizer mechaniker
[Musik]
sein name ist brust in er spricht
erstmals öffentlich über seine
erlebnisse
gestützt auf seine informationen hätten
die westlichen geheimdienste auf einem
frachter im oktober 2003 verdeckt unter
containern atombomben teile gefunden
sagt er
das kann netzwerk ist entlarvt
ich bin super slow motion dass schuldner
also nur weiß noch nicht was via
internet oder
justina ist der traum jedes
geheimdienstes er liefert informationen
und ist gleichzeitig in der lage im
netzwerk weiter zu arbeiten
[Musik]
das rheintal diese gegend besonders die
freundschaft haag gefällt in den 70er
jahren einen pakistanischen
wissenschaftler die stimme gehört ihm
take you kann ist ein berühmter mann in
pakistan
er gilt als der vater der pakistanischen
atombombe
im mai 1998 ist es soweit
pakistan zündet unterirdisch seinen
nuklearen sprengsatz
die sogenannte islamische atombombe
[Musik]
educon wird als held gefeiert pakistan
hatte große probleme mit seiner
sicherheit pokal löste diese in einer
unkonventionellen weise indem er die
bombe baute dafür reist er in der ganzen
welt herum er offerierte seine dienste
damals dem pakistanischen präsidenten
und sammelte um sich eine team von
offizieren wissenschaftler und
ingenieure
die nation ist ihm deshalb zu dank
verpflichtet
er ist ohne zweifel ein großer
nationalheld
am telefon gibt gern auskunft zu seiner
rheintal bindung auf deutsch der nacht
vor vielen vielen jahren in berlin
studiert das wohnhaus der familie tinner
im rheintal vater friedrich tinner ist
ein begabter ingenieur und
leidenschaftlicher funkamateur kann und
er verstehen sich gut
friedrich tinner kann seinem freund auch
beim atombombenbau helfen kam ist
deshalb oft hier zu gast
zu dieser zeit geht er keine roos noch
zur schule ankam könne er sich nicht
erinnern er habe andere sorgen gehabt
der malische lustig macht bis zu 6 klar
denn ich mir vom meer gebaut worden oder
untersagt wurde
sekundarschule prüfung abschlussklasse
handke sprints braucht es ist es
dreifach die schulbildung hat schon die
wir haben in ihren 77 gelernt wir waren
dabei und hatten etwas exportmanager und
entscheiden haben
der junge kann in holland anfangs der
70er jahre
er arbeitet als wissenschaftler in der
urenco einem gemeinschaftsunternehmen
des westens hier wird uran für die
atomkraftwerke so genannt angereichert
ein streng geheimes verfahren denn mit
angereichertem uran kann man auch
atombomben bauen
die sich das spiel dort heino rango
brauchte ihn damals den begabten
wissenschaftler als sie diese uran
zentrifugen zu entwickeln begannen dann
realisierte dass er auf einem enormen
berg von sehr nützlichen informationen
sind spricht perfektes englisch aber
auch holländischen deutsch
er konnte alle dokumentationen lesen
er startete seine nukleare karriere in
pakistan in dem er einen brief an den
damaligen präsidenten beschrieb er könne
technologie und wissen über
urananreicherung stehen
der damalige pakistanische präsident
bouton besichtigt an den importierten
atomreaktor motto will die atombombe
doch der westen verweigert jede hilfe
pakistan selbst scheint unfähig eine
bombe allein zu bauen als kam nach
pakistan zurückkehrte war das land kaum
in der lage nähnadeln zu produzieren und
trotzdem gelang es ihm eine
funktionstüchtige effiziente nukleare
organisation aufzubauen und dann nutzte
er seine kontakte quer durch europa um
ausrüstungen für pakistans
urananreicherungsprogramm zu kaufen
als er nach pakistan zurückkehrte nahm
er nicht nur die urenco pläne mit
sondern und so kam er mit tinas in
kontakt er nahm auch die lieferliste mit
die namen liste derjenigen die
ausrüstung rohmaterial und technologie
an urenco lieferte der name tinner war
auf die ohren kuli verlierst du die kam
mit sich nahm und täters wurden kann
auch empfohlen durch wissenschaftler die
kahn kennen und schätzen lernte als er
in deutschland und läufern studierte
und hier können sie diese großartige
organisatorische begabung von kann
erkennen dass sogenannte vakuum welle in
der schweiz
diese quelle von technologie dorthin
muss sich wie bundesarchiv wer hier
lagern die akten über kahns erste
schweizer kontakte vergessen und unter
verschluss das schweizer fernsehen fand
die dossiers und erhielt die
ausnahmebewilligung die bisher
vertraulichen und nie publizierten
dokumente einzusehen
sogar die visitenkarte vom damaligen vrt
engineer friedrich tinner ist hier
abgelegt tinner informierte damals offen
über den export antrag für eine vakuum
anlage pakistan benötige so tina die
ware für eine geplante
urananreicherungsanlage wehren wusste
also genau bescheid und erlaubte am 12
august 1977 den export trotzdem
in seiner offiziellen biografie
publiziert 1992 dank take you kann dafür
der schweiz
so sei er zur wichtigsten ausrüstung
gekommen die schweizer regierung also
ist mitverantwortlich für die nukleare
fähigkeit pakistans washington
protestiert damals energisch droht der
schweiz deswegen sogar mit
wirtschaftssanktionen es wird hin und
her geschrieben vertraulich confidential
während im rheintal vater thema weiter
mit kann geschäftet überlegt sich sohnes
was er werden könnte ja ein sehr schöner
auch lehrer machen ja als auch
geschnuppert hat eine app an mechanik
job gemacht und hat eine mechanik kim
hak neunzehnter märz 1979 der
amerikanische geheimdienst macht die
schweiz auf eine rheintal reise von
äthiopien aufmerksam
doch nichts passiert kann reist noch oft
ins rheintal zu vater friedrich tinner
der inzwischen die firma avp verlassen
und ein eigenes unternehmen gegründet
hat kommen erzählt am telefon
wie sie geld verlieren
probleme gibt es erst im jahre 2004 kahn
wird den islamabad festgenommen
verraten vom sohn seines
geschäftspartners friedrich tinner von
justina der inzwischen zum spion
geworden ist mussten
seit ende 2008 ist auf freiem fuß über
vier jahre verbrachte er in schweizer
untersuchungshaft
zu unrecht wie er sagt alles beginnt mit
problemen in der schweiz ganze theater
mit problem hat es versucht irgendwie
die schulter was ich hab's zahler und
irgendwo sind einfach situation sieht
als sie vor der qual wie das problem
kann objekte stück einfach sie sind oder
nicht fertig sind dass ich seitdem muss
er den ball weg ich weiß noch mal wie es
oft dubiose und wir stehen dubai in
frage kommt für mich einfach wichtig
im november 1998 fliegt aus dem nach
dubai warum ausgerechnet dubai ein
vorschlag seines vaters der wenige
monate vorher kam in dubai traf daran
den osten er sich nicht erinnern können
tatsache ist jedenfalls dass trainer
trifft ebenfalls auf kam dem freund
seines vaters ich vielleicht der 32 wie
sie schon mal im ausland schon mit
verstand und plötzlich und ein ort mit
ihm plötzlich ein reh damit fehlt geld
auch er kann erinnert sich im
telefoninterview anderes thema
eigentlich hört denkt das was man im
norden hin auch vorzüge verletzt ganz
monika voll mit bildern völker sehr sehr
stark von blumen also sehr
naturverbunden
es ist jene zeit in der die
pakistanische armee finanzprobleme hat
die usa haben ihre unterstützung gekürzt
unter anderem weil sie mit der nuklearen
aufrüstung pakistans nicht einverstanden
sind
die pakistanische militär und
geheimdienst führung warnte die usa wenn
wir uns nach dem sowjet rückzug aus
afghanistan die mittel kürzt müssen wir
andere methoden finden
die warnung war allgemeiner natur später
wurden sie konkreter wenn ihr uns die
finanzielle unterstützung streicht
werden wir unsere nukleartechnologie
verkaufen
1991 begann pakistan diese drohungen
wahr zu machen kann erhält den auftrag
der beginnt die technologie anderen
nationen anzubieten kam drehte den fluss
importeur zum exporteur
er verkaufte pakistans atomwaffen
geheimnisse und teile des
urananreicherungsprogramms an iran
nordkorea und libyen
er offerierte es auch den irak
errichtete unermesslichen schaden an
indem er atomwaffen weiterverkaufte es
gibt keinen zweifel kann arbeitete für
die geschäfte als vertreter seine
regierung
es gab in der welt kein anderes netzwerk
der so groß und so bedeutend war wie das
sie kochen das wissen vertreiben wie man
urananreicherung zentrifugen baut und
betreibt
aber zusätzlich da hatten sie auch
informationen über den bau von
atomwaffen und dieses material war auch
lieferbar für die kunden dieses so
genannten netzwerkes dubai ist der
schauplatz dieses wandels tukan hat hier
eine wohnung gemietet
und wer hat hier eine art
geschäftsführer eingesetzt den zeeland
käsen bsa hier da hier spielt eine
schlüsselrolle
daher ist mechanisch erstellter aufbau
zum mond ihrer zu teilehersteller
normalen mechanischen angestellte
unserem tanzen und eines tages konnte
daher und zeitdokumente scanner
er will dem papier kränker hätte die
firma computer aufgestellt hat ist
zunächst ein hartes los und die
bibliothek sowie beachtet und zum teil
auch mit quentin diese dokumente hat
kann in seinem büro oder in seiner
wohnung in dubai aufbewahrt
er besaß eine residenz dort es waren
rund zehn bis zwölf piloten koffer voll
mit plänen roth instruktionen
einige hatten zu tun mit zentrifugen
anderem mit uranium metallkunde und
andere offensichtlich mit nuklearwaffen
man könnte es kahns bibliothek nennen
und sie enthält einige der wichtigsten
nuklearen geheimnisse dieser welt hier
haben wir jemanden wir sehr eng mit
nordkorea mit iran und mit china vor
allem mit china zusammengearbeitet hat
das war ein hoch geheime dokumente die
nur wenige wissenschaftler und
geheimdienstleute sehen durften designs
für kleine atombombe pläne für neueste
anreicherungstechnologie
die zahl war sehr hoch
es waren glaube ich mehr als 100 sehr
große zeichnungen
der elektro ins und sollte computer hat
man einfach installiert dass der
computer-hersteller kopie auftakt ist
gemacht oder von novartis gemacht und
dabei weil es macht er zum teil ii das
ist ein fehler dass es auf der datenbank
speichert auf dem computer gespeichert
und auch das duett oder kopiert ruf für
sind und nach ein anfang in denen essen
noch ebenso sorgen auch die zukunft was
muss kennt man automatisch abgeordnete
die rede ist matthias gemacht ja vor der
scanner erhält man natürlich logischer
wie ist in sachen könnte dokument hält
man an der leistung folgen
sie sind acht bruder urenkel sachen
dokumentenmanagement web seite mit ari
fritzlar mit irgendwas games team wohl
im begriff was das 15 lange umgang mit
internet und logen und da hätten wir
natürlich über so zusammenhänge büro
miteinander von cannes haben
recherchiert mcchrystal strahlen was
macht oder oder was mit dem verkäufer
irgendwo ist mobil blitzartig irgend in
gießen wo sie gerne greens event die
dokumente die er kopierte sorgen heute
in der schweiz für aufsehen und haben
parlamentarischen sonderbericht
verursacht noch aber sagt aus tanner
habe er keinen kontakt mit
geheimdiensten gehabt die gelegenheit
habe sich erst später ergeben in
malaysia in der firma aus gummi nach
auffliegen des netzwerkes darf die
presse hier kurzfilm tahir und kahn
hatten geschlossen
in dieser firma heimlich teile für das
nuklearprogramm produzieren zu lassen
durch rost in china sagt er habe hier in
eigeninitiative versucht den
geheimdienst auf sich aufmerksam zu
machen
mit einem abgeänderten uran zentrifugen
bestehen die umstellung wenn wenn iran
im das ktm startet irgendwer das macht
die firma stellt sie uns und wenn
irgendwer dahinter ist wahr dass wörter
besuchs lösten
denn dem moment höre davon irgendwann
ich mit zum kontakt mit ribéry will das
sind sachen und zog sich das integriert
diese rekrutiert das thema ende 1999
oder anfangs 2000 und amadou zu einem
wichtigen informanten über die
aktivitäten des ltk netzwerkes jemanden
mit diesem zugang in einer organisation
zu haben das ist unschlagbar
justine war wirklich der traum jedes
geheimdienstes
er sichert man sich hier telefonieren
ins event und er und wo will sie müssten
es wird abgelöst und da gibt es so viele
sachen sind einfach ist ein schwieriges
leben aber und sie sehen die irgendwo
ein zimmer rasch dass in flüssen zum
teil teilten sie im hoch sind dass sie
schließen die türen 1live bis zum
schlafzimmer aus dem schlimmsten sind
wir sehr verwirklichte gibt wo sie
angestellt oder oder situationen gamer
leise ironie minimiert und das hotel
wohne ich seit ich wieder am anfang
scheint dass sich irgend möglich
man kann sich kaum vorstellen in seiner
haut zu stecken
jeden tag diesen druck jeden tag die
bange frage habe ich auf liebe und wer
weiß was passiert wäre wenn er
aufgeflogen wäre bevor er die wichtigen
informationen den geheimdienst hat
übergeben können sagt aus
sicherheitsgründen habe er seine
informationen ins rheintal geschickt
dort habe sich sein bruder marco an die
serie weitergeleitet
es sei sein bruder marco gewesen der im
jahr 2003 mit der cia an den vertrag
abschloss erstens die ganze nacht
gemacht den vertrag mit sport oder
inmitten und geschafft sich in spiesen
über für reiser und verschiedene sachen
der insgesamt 1 million eigene stärke
gesamte familie kinder die hcl wenig
gewachsen und das gilt wohl nie wieder
gehen
ich habe finanziell nicht so gerne ich
denn jetzt tun können
vierter oktober 2003
im mittelmeer steuert die italienische
küstenwache auf den deutschen frachter
bbc china zu zusammen mit agenten des
amerikanischen und britischen
geheimdienstes
[Musik]
das aufbringen der bbc china im jahr
2003 war das wichtigste ereignis ohne
das hätten wir wohl gaddafi den
libyschen herrscher nicht überzeugen
können
sein atomprogramm aufzugeben
hier seien mehr und die öffentlichkeit
die bestandteile und das ausmass des
projektes und das half wahrscheinlich
libyen zu gestehen
die beschlagnahmung des materials auf
dem schiff bbc china am prächtigen clan
beweis der involvierung des netzwerkes
sie verkauften buchstäblich von a bis z
alles um eine atombombe
auf der bbc scheiner wissen die
geheimagenten genau was sie suchen
müssen
aus der riesigen menge von containern
wählen sie gezielt fünf behälter aus
versteckt unter anderem containern diese
information stammt von ihm sagt oster
oder zu große risiko ein
meistens ist man muss das material aus
dem verzicht auf den start warten
kopieren drucken will das falsch
passierte schätzt papier zweimal
komplett und hetzen übergeworfen solcher
kopien proxy und dann ist das richtig
von der sekretärin factor oder und wenn
er mal minute lang war das papier wie
den iren sollen die informationen ohne
ihn und seine information hätten sie
vermutlich das schiff nicht aufbringen
können
noch am gleichen tag befiehlt tahir
austin dazu sich nach dubai er vermutet
tanner habe ihn und kann verraten
versucht umsatz vorsicht
daher ist schnell ernähre geständig not
worden und hat versucht ersatz
verhindern wurde verändern die kinder
erklärt ihm er könne es nicht gewesen
sein
der frachter sei erst auf der zweiten
reiseetappe dubai libyen gestoppt worden
und nicht bereits zwischen malaysia und
dubai
das ist verantwortet dass es nicht
zwischen den hof führt wird dürfen sich
total klasse wusste wo der fehler liegt
und als sichel volkstanz dass das mofa
unter wert die amerikanischen behörden
präsentieren später die ausrüstungen die
sie nach auffliegen der bbc china in
libyen beschlagnahmen uran zentrifugen
und kisten mit pakistanischen
beschriftungen direktlieferungen aus
pakistan
der damalige präsident george hw bush
besichtigt persönlich den fund ich habe
gerade diese gefährlichen teile
besichtigt heute ist die welt und libyen
sichere wahl diese bestandteile
beschlagnahmt wurden
libyen hat das atomwaffen und
langstreckenraketen programm aufgegeben
ich glaube einfach dass die das die
zerschlagung des wahrscheinlich größten
und umfangreichsten privaten exports für
nukleares material und know how die welt
sicherer gemacht hat es ist für mich
eine schreckliche vorstellung zu
überlegen das kann noch 20 30 jahre
weitergemacht hätte
kyu kahn wird in pakistan auf druck der
amerikaner vorläufig festgenommen das
netzwerk ist gestoppt
[Musik]
bern bundeshaus noch weiß die
öffentlichkeit nichts von austin us
rolle
doch die schweizer regierung wird ins
vertrauen gezogen wie der ehemalige
justizminister erstmals bestätigt
verschiedene staaten wo es lang sind und
mit dem fall tinner
das ist ein sehr heikler fall der ecke
große bedeutung bei der nichtverbreitung
von atomwaffen
die atomenergie agentur wie sie
überwacht und kontrolliert international
atomen die atomenergie agentur wird
ebenfalls sofort alarmiert der mittlere
ist nach libyen um die vorwürfe
abzuklären
sie sehen dass die zentrifugen
pakistanischer bauart sind lea bone
technology libysche regierung gab das
programm zimmer und so flogen elbaradei
ich uns andere an weihnachten 2003 nach
libyen bis hin zum ersten mal ihre
zentrifugen und dann war ich sofort klar
gleich größe gleiche bauart
der libysche militärakademie die ware
auf dem schiff bbc china war für ihn
bestimmt für sein geheimes atomprogramm
jetzt ist plötzlich alles bekannt
gaddafi unter druck entscheidet sich
offen zu kooperieren
einer der libyschen leiter des
anreicherungsprogramm sagte unseld uk
habe ihm am ende eines treffens einen
vielleicht zwei plastiksäcke erreicht
mit dokumenten und kann habe ihm gesagt
wenn sie einmal etwas weiter sind mit
der urananreicherung können für sie
diese dokumente hilfreich sein
atombomben pläne überreicht in einem
plastiksack mit diesem aufdruck
der ausdruck führt zurück nach pakistan
zum good looks and vertragsgeschäft es
ist ein plastiksack aus dieser
schneiderei dem bevorzugten geschäft von
eco kann
und tatsächlich finden wir hier sein
bild diese dokumente waren ganz anders
nicht über zentrifugen technologie
sondern es ging hier um den bau von
nuklearwaffen
sie bieten ziemlich relativ schnell bin
ich ein glas oder für firmen immer leise
hat dann kritiker zum klang der barriere
zwischen winter- oder oder seite im
monat ist geändert hat ist cctv der
eppinger die uhrzeit testat vernichtend
das und die hat das zeug einfach
mitgenommen
das wieder gehen musste
reist zurück in die heimat
seine arbeit als spion ist zu ende jetzt
beginnt eine neue phase
er sein bruder marco und vater fred
tanner fahren nach wien
sie treffen olli heinonen von der
atomenergie agentur im hotel
intercontinental
retter.tv retina sagte sie wollten über
ihre beteiligung sprechen
er sagte er habe das gefühl sie könnten
und müssten uns bei den ermittlungen
helfen investoren natürlich für
maschinen umzurüsten
mit rund so teile einzeln einzige
metallhydrid zum teil heitmanns gruppe
miteinander etats mitreiten können dann
hätten viele jahre wie es mit dem tag
jetzt kommt torres mit verschiedener
sachen store kann man hat gewusst wie
zeichnungen uns sind es gibt details
löser was ich mit verstrickt
an mehreren sitzungen wird das ecklokal
netzwerk mit tinas hilfe durchleuchtet
weil wir so die organisation dieses
netzwerkes verstehen konnten und
erfuhren über welche informationen es
verfügte tinners informieren die
atomenergie agentur auch über den
sensibelsten teil von kans aktivitäten
die hochgeheimen atombomben pläne die in
elektronischer form vorliegen
als sie uns die existenz von
informationen in elektronischer form
erklärten waren wir in der lage unsere
ermittlungen anders zu gestalten
wir konnten dann einige von diesen
dokumenten geschlagen haben
wenige monate später mitte 2005 der fall
in deine neue wände die schweizer justiz
hatte zuerst aus tanner später aus
seinem bruder marco und vater tanner
hauptvorwurf export von nuklearem
kriegsmaterial unter anderem in den
behältern die auf der bbc china mit
austin us hilfe entdeckt worden sind
die polizei beschlagnahmt auch die
elektronischen bomben pläne
diese habe er der atomenergie agentur
iaea vorlegen wollen sagt tanner
das wären 16 16 mission termine anstehen
da nicht für den termin um das thema
krieg und die dokumenten 13
kennzeichnungs sie das vde aussieht
justina sitzt jetzt in untersuchungshaft
er gilt in der öffentlichkeit als
gefährlicher nuklear schmuggler als
bösewicht als skrupelloser bombenbauer
in bern hingegen merken die behörden
zuerst nicht auf was für heiklen
papieren sie sitzen bis die
bundesanwaltschaft olli heinonen von der
atomenergie agentur zu rate zieht der
damalige justizminister blocher erinnert
sich bundesanwaltschaft den haag seit
mehr handy dem fall tinner sehr heikel
unterlage dass ich fest stellt von der
internationalen atomenergieagentur iaeo
so sad wir haben den schweizer behörden
auch gesagt dass es material gebe das
mit nuklearwaffen bau zu tun habe
zusätzlich zum zentrifugen material
welche sie auch schon ziemlich heikel
ist für diese dokumente braucht man ein
spezielles wissen es ist nicht einfach
zu verstehen
das ist für nuklearwaffen das ist für
etwas anderes
deshalb operierten wir der schweiz
unsere hilfe
auch das weiße haus mischt sich jetzt
ein der schweizer justizminister blocher
reist im sommer 2007 nach washington
die verhaftung ihres spiels austin durch
die schweizer behörden stößt hier auf
unverständnis
da sich de talca bin und wer iraners chf
also öffentlich bekannt
ihre themen hacke wunderbar das thema
das habe ich brauche die usa wollen von
der schweiz auch die beschlagnahmten
bomben pläne
vielleicht weil dort auch amerikanische
geheimnisse enthalten sind will darf er
für sie sich als sie und ihr harmlose
silber zöge das marine das dekret kurz
luftloch aus rückkehr fällt der
bundesrat in die ersten entschluss er
verbietet die tinners als spione
anzuklagen
im falle von spionage ist der bundesrat
dazu gesetzlich ermächtigt warum macht
aber sie mussten unter teils der
bundesrat ausgestoßen hunderte
internationale sicherheits kontext wenn
man das der ermächtigung anteil kette
zum der strafverfolgungs macher nicht
verbieten kann der bundesrat die justiz
gegen themas wegen lieferungen von
nuklearmaterial zu ermitteln doch der
bundesrat fällt wenig später einen
weiteren beschluss der die untersuchung
beeinträchtigt er beschließt gegen den
willen der bundesanwaltschaft die
beschlagnahmten bomben pläne zu
vernichten
der speicher der name tatsächlich vor
allem die debatte land verwüstet wurde
frau bundesrätin calmy-rey der da ist
clarke seitigen unterlage aus bundesamt
für justiz hat das bestätigen und vor
allem die internationale
atomenergieagentur es auf das wissen
über helping bleiben wir helfen ihnen
die heiklen dokumente zu identifizieren
es war ihre entscheidung diese zu
zerstören unsere leute waren dort es war
wichtig einen sehr genauen katalog zu
erstellen über das was zerstört würde
denn falls dieser fallen wieder aktuell
wird ist es wichtig zu wissen was dort
war atombombe baue so lang war vermietet
bruchlinie atombombe wehtun zu wieder
gas in unglaublich interessante sache
und was passiert die sonnige sagt wenn
man weiß dass mir das an
langsam wird genau angesprochen hätte
das land auf eine ablassen qantas
passiert dass das rra bis zur thüringer
gtx vor denn sie brauchten mehrere
wochen für die zerstörung
sie gingen systematisch vor jedes
dokument wurde identifiziert und benannt
sowie das zerstörungs datum festgehalten
die papiere wurden geschreddert und
verbrannt computer hard disks wurden
unlesbar gemacht und schließlich noch
zerstampft
die enttäusche ganze großes
sicherheitsrisiko für das land
[Musik]
die internationale atomenergie agentur
prüft die tinner information weiter sie
fährt fort mit der analyse des car
netzwerkes und sie stößt auf iran
es war sehr klar für uns dass wir genau
hinschauen müssen und es schien dass es
verbindungen richtung iran gab die leute
die informationen und teile an iran
weitergaben schienen die gleichen zu
sein wie diejenigen die teile an libyen
lieferten
der iranische dokumentarfilme dem titel
wir können
bombastisch wird das angeblich
friedliche atomprogramm erklärt
fakt ist dass iran die technologie
ursprünglich von eco kahn erhalten hatte
fakt ist auch iran erlebt mehrere
rückschläge in folge sabotage im film
erklärt der leiter des programms was
genau passiert ist wie er besorgnis
irgendwie solche zentrifugen pumpen in
einem europäischen land als wir sie
einsetzen explodierten die zentrifugen
nach einer diagnose stellten wir fest
dass die pumpen die man uns verkauft
hatte manipuliert waren
sie waren so manipuliert dass die
maschinen explodierten
sie wollten uns täuschen wenn nicht aus
denen wir sonst
es muss ihm und gewesen sein der im
netzwerk war damit er die sabotierten
teile einschleusen konnte ich denke aus
sinne ist der verdächtige nummer eins
bezüglich sabotage
als urs tinner im schweizer gefängnis
sitzt besucht olli heinonen ihn
sie sprechen unter anderem über sabotage
bisher brauchten immer noch ihre hilfe
wir setzen unsere ermittlungen fort und
es gab neue informationen sich im
entringer gang teil ihrer früheren aus
einem teil sind style und aluminiumteile
heldmann gemacht israelisch aluminium
see und klinisches röhrlich segel stahl
beweis dass die sache warenwert und und
salome die um trainings koeffizient vor
allem mini um das größte als regel stahl
dass züge zweimal bis sie sehr schwül
warm wird auf betriebstemperatur
dann wird's aluminium größer und den
kennt die passion passiver selber rosen
an
und das sind so sachen wo
funktionstüchtig sehen bis sie sehr
schmal recht laufen dann zur balz auf
temperatur wischhusen zu unterer lech
posen und und passiert medial auf zwar
aber sced produkt das sind so sachen um
mit dem haydn nachgelagert wohin die
sabotierten teile gingen bisher nicht
sagt hannah die schweizer justiz hat
wären den jahrelangen ermittlungen nicht
untersucht ob tina an der iran sabotage
beteiligt war
die behörde sagt ein gutachten habe
ergeben dass kans ware für libyen nicht
sabotiert worden sei
educon er steht heute unter hausarrest
er wurde nie verurteilt er darf zu hause
zwar keine ausländischen journalisten
mehr empfangen aber telefonische
interviews gibt er mit dem
amerikanischen geheimdienst
zusammengearbeitet haben so art gelungen
man muss mich nicht selbst gegen den
milden hausarrest von erkan protestieren
islamische parteien in pakistan mit
demonstrationen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kan ist unser held unser wird unser
hippler er hat großartiges für pakistan
soll die welt doch zur hölle gehen wenn
sie sagt er ist ein schmuggler
er ist kein schmuggler der ehemalige
geheimdienstchef google hat enge
kontakte zu extremistischen islamisten
und erkennt osama bin laden will osama
bin laden die atombombe ich weiß es
nicht
wir haben nicht darüber gesprochen als
ich ihn getroffen habe aber es ist krieg
amerika reif zu allen mitteln
es ist möglich es gibt keinen zweifel
dass osama bin laden und seine al qaida
organisation eine atombombe möchten die
amerikaner zerstören aufs brutalste die
zivilisation und kultur afghanistan im
krieg ist also alles erlaubt
pakistan
ihr fehlt offenbar hoch angereichertes
bomben fähiges uranium in den drk nur
sechs laboratorien als die pakistanische
regierung nach khans absetzung die erste
richtige betriebsprüfung machte
entdeckte sie dass große mengen
verschwunden waren
wohin sind sie verschwunden hat man sie
dem iran gegeben möglich nordkorea
möglich wurde irgendwo hin sonst die
tatsache dass es bezüglich waffenfähiges
uran ihm überhaupt ein fragezeichen gibt
ist allein schon beängstigend es gibt
reale angst darüber wohin das material
verschwand und ob es immer noch auf dem
markt zu verkaufen ist pakistan ist
meiner meinung nach das gefährlichste
land der welt albträume der welt kommen
hier in einer einzigartig explosiven
weise zusammen
[Musik]
wir haben das problem der verbreitung
von nukleartechnologie symbolisiert
durch das 11 uk netzwerk wir haben die
sehr ernste gefahr eines krieges
zwischen indien und pakistan im letzten
jahrzehnt waren die beiden länder schon
zweimal fast im kriegszustand und ein
solcher krieg kann leicht einen
nuklearkrieg werden
wir haben das problem des terrorismus
die heimat von al qaida ist heute
pakistan kann ist eben nicht nur ein
schmuggler gewesen von technologien
sondern es eben auch ein schmuggler
gewesen von von wissen und wenn wissen
einmal verteilt wurde in unserer
heutigen welt dann verteilt er sich
immer schneller
[Musik]
immerhin gaddafi musste sein
atomprogramm aufgeben und irans programm
erlebt dank sabotage rückschläge musste
aber hat seine mitarbeit in der schweiz
kein glück gebracht
die hvb u haft verbracht und das im
fjord wo sie innere zähler
primo zwei meter groß größer viel licht
setzen wo sie ihr sprechender mann
aufseiten ansprechen sind sie sitzen
sie hängt fast nützt oder sogar das
irgendwie beschäftigen und die halbjahr
überall halbjahr die installation
gesehen das heißt ja kein kontakt zu mit
ins aus ich habe außer der wertung iss
verbracht hat und vielleicht erfahrener
mann in magdeburg und das ist es wo
meine mails sehr viel gemacht für die
internationale atomenergieagentur gibt
es noch immer offene fragen
wissen immer noch nicht wo überall
solche dokumente gespeichert waren
deshalb müssen wir unsere ermittlungen
fortsetzen
die fabrik von vater tinner ist
inzwischen geschlossen
die räume zu vermieten justina sagt er
fürchtete die rache des aufgedeckten
netzwerkes
es gibt leute haben viel geld verloren
es genügt die hand das projekt mit lok
und schlussendlich wird man in sachen
man entschuldige gleich wie es ist
wissenschaft lebt irgendwo wird immer
schuldiger gesucht
das prinzip ist wahrscheinlich dass
schuldner
man weiß noch nicht was wir endet oder
die bundesanwaltschaft und die sie
lehnen jede auskunft ab
eine anklage gegen marco und vater
friedrich tinner wegen lieferungen von
nuklearem kriegsmaterial ist nicht in
sicht
trotz jahrelanger untersuchung
[Musik]